Mission: Incredible or Mission:
Unbearable? Here's the best and worst of
Tom Cruise's greatest action franchise.
First of all, it's worth pointing out that
being the "worst" in an indisputably phenomenal
franchise isn't such a bad thing. It's not
that director John Woo's submission to the
IMF compendium is bad, per se, it's just that it
doesn't hold a candle to the other five films.
The movie pairs Tom Cruise's Ethan Hunt with
professional thief Nyah Hall as they battle
her ex-boyfriend — who also happens to be a rogue
IMF agent. The baddie in this one is attempting
to steal a deadly virus and start a worldwide
pandemic — a plotline that has arguably aged
better than anyone could have guessed at the time.
Either way, Mission: Impossible II is not the
strongest of the series, and it would be six years
before Ethan chose to accept his next mission.
Yes, the stunt on the Burj Khalifa is cool.
Nobody's denying that. But that scene doesn't
make up for Paula Patton's painful turn as
Jane, or Jeremy Renner's unbearably whiny
Brandt. If it wasn't for his wisecracking buddy
Benji, Ethan might have thought about scrapping
the entire team and starting fresh after Ghost
Protocol. But in fairness, director Brad Bird's
franchise entry does an excellent job of setting
up the so-called "dashies;" the most recent three
films in the franchise, which take a decidedly
cooler approach than the three that preceded them.
"Mission accomplished!"
The major set pieces lose a little urgency
when you're watching them on a small screen,
but all is forgiven for the
movie's most thrilling moments:
Benji inciting a Russian prison riot against
his better judgment, for example, or he and
Ethan using virtual reality trickery to break into
the Kremlin. That's the IMF we all know and love.
There's nothing quite like
an original — or, at least,
an adaptation of the real original. If nothing
else, though, the existence of the Mission:
Impossible TV series just goes to show that the
party never starts until Tom Cruise shows up.
It's hard to overstate the impact of Mission:
Impossible when it debuted in 1996. This was a
movie that killed off half the cast in the first
half hour, delivered a stealth scene so iconic
it would be parodied for years to come, and, of
course, introduced a new generation to an iconic
theme song. Perhaps a good example of how the
first of the franchise shook the status quo is
the fact that audiences were originally baffled —
some even angry — at how complicated and confusing
the plot was. If you rewatch it today, however,
you'll experience a storyline that feels as
elegant as it is easy to follow.
The top three Mission: Impossible movies
are a little trickier to parse, because,
honestly, they're all great. Mission:
Impossible III, by director J.J. Abrams,
marked the end of one era and the
beginning of another; every Mission:
Impossible is bigger and bolder than the
last, but the films that follow this one
scale up considerably in terms of
stunts, scope, and storytelling.
Mission: Impossible III sets up that change just
right, introducing us to Ethan Hunt's foray into
domestic life and bringing back crowd favorite
Luther, establishing that, for Ethan Hunt, people
matter more than politics. As such, the film also
kicks off a question Hunt will be attempting to
answer for the next three flicks: How can he
save the world and the people he cares about?
The movie was the lowest-grossing of
the franchise, and reviews were mixed,
but standout performances
by Keri Russell and Philip
Seymour Hoffman suggest it's a lot
better than it was given credit for.
"Oh, that was nothing. That was… fun."
Moreover, it's a joy to see all the emotional
themes that were established in this movie and
carried on by the rest: Ethan Hunt as
a mentor, Ethan Hunt as a man in love,
Ethan Hunt as a team player and an all-around
good guy. All in all, a retrospective viewing
gives the third installment a shine that critics
might not have seen when it premiered in 2006.
Mission: Impossible — Fallout
is the most recent film of the
franchise, and it picks up where its
predecessor, Rogue Nation, left off.
Ethan Hunt and the gang are still hot on the
heels of the Syndicate — a shadowy organization
composed of former field operatives who have
since become mercenaries. A new version of the
Syndicate called the Apostles has wacky ideas
about plutonium, dirty bombs, and suffering
leading to a new world order, among other things.
None of this really matters, though, because
if you're watching Fallout, you're probably on
board with whatever the IMF is up to these days.
Many favorite faces return in Fallout, but new
additions to the cast, such as Henry Cavill and
Angela Bassett, make the film even more fun. The
movie feels like a genuine rollercoaster ride,
with non-stop action, breathless ups and downs,
and a few loop-de-loops thrown in for good
measure. It's this movie that makes you realize
that, no matter how far-fetched or implausible
these flicks might get, you're always in good
hands with Christopher McQuarrie and Tom Cruise.
Picking a favorite in the Mission: Impossible
series is difficult, but not altogether
impossible. Case in point: Rogue Nation.
Not only does this movie introduce Alec
Baldwin and Sean Harris, the latter of whom
is arguably the franchise's best villain,
but Christopher McQuarrie takes the
whole series from good to great.
"Gentleman, this is Solomon
Lane. Mr. Lane… meet the IMF."
McQuarrie knows you can't just stack
cool fight scenes on top of one another,
so he uses clever jokes, stunning visuals, and
well-written characters to create a house of
cards so perfect you'll be holding your breath
and praying it doesn't all come crashing down.
Tom Cruise cements the movie, of course, with the
same charisma that won hearts in the first film,
but what knocks Rogue Nation into
the top spot is Rebecca Ferguson,
who makes her franchise debut with
the character of Ilsa Faust. Faust
is more than a match for Hunt, and
she steals every scene she's in.
Throw it all together and you've got the best
Mission: Impossible movie — though, with McQuarrie
and Cruise set to return for Dead Reckoning,
this one may not be in the top spot for long.